i don't know about you but my fingers
are always crossed for good horror and
this video is brought to you by cook
unity gonna talk about that a little
later but first it's a horror movie
there's no embargo it's like both movies
this week had embargoes that had already
lifted before the week even started it's
a good science my friend
so black phone is a new film directed by
scott derrickson yes he directed doctor
strange but more notably or at least
comparable to this movie he directed
sinister and before that the exorcism of
emily rose which i think is an
underrated movie in terms of
supernatural horror also courtroom drama
so that mix of horror and drama he
brings to black phone and when i saw it
with scott derrickson i was like i'm in
sinister was one of those movies when i
saw it i was like a movie hasn't creeped
me out like that in years and even to my
recollection i don't think a movie's
creeped me out as much as sinister since
sinister in the first one anyway second
one was [ __ ] and as much as i called
this movie horror in the intro it's a
little more complex than that thriller
yes suspense absolutely supernatural
elements that point to horror yes but
the true horror in this movie
is that which is more real and that's in
the premise the premise is there's this
guy played by ethan hawk he's called the
grabber and he kidnaps and murders
children then he kidnaps our lead so the
main premise is this kid is in the
cellar and there's this phone that rings
and this is where the supernatural
element comes in and it sounds way more
cheese with me explaining it than it is
in the movie the movie actually pulls it
off really well he can talk with the
spirits of the murdered children that
this guy is murdered so they're kind of
collaborating with him to try to get him
out of here and really that's one of the
many things in this movie that's
executed in a way that's just attention
to detail that
makes it feel special it keeps it from
feeling mundane or at least cookie
cutter or familiar now really the first
act of this movie is all character setup
you know it's establishing the family
dynamic the relationship between the
brother and sister leeds played by
madeleine mcgraw and mason thames themes
are famous i'm terrible with names but i
thought their characters were amazingly
relatable and more importantly when the
scenes were heavier was when they really
shine scenes of fear tension water works
intensity that's when i'm like oh these
kids are really good and i can't
emphasize the tension in this movie
enough especially from the kidnapper
himself played by ethan hawk but i like
the fact that you don't really ever see
ethan hawk he's always wearing this
devil mask which right there also creepy
but he is a child kidnapper murderer it
doesn't matter the mask he is wearing
any mask would be creepy could be a
double mask a smiley face emoji a
[ __ ] pokemon head regardless it would
always be creepy with this guy but i
like the fact that the devil mask has an
interchangeable mouthpiece that emotes
the emotion that he's feeling it's just
right there that's what i'm talking
about these details in this movie where
they didn't have to do
but i like that they did that there's
some actors out there that you just get
the feeling to like well if i'm going to
be in the movie you need to see my face
regardless of what it does to the
character then there are actors like
ethan hawk in this role where you just
get the feeling he was like
as long as it's best for the movie it
doesn't matter also when the kid's
talking on the phone with spirits you
know so you're thinking sixth sense
meets silence of the lambs kind of
actually if i had to pitch this movie
that's exactly what i would say but
right there you see the spirit of the
kid talking to the main kid but the main
kid can't see the spirit of the kid you
can just hear him on the phone and the
phone has that crackly scratchy
talking on the phone audio to it but
when the spirit of the kid's talking you
see his mouth moving so it's it's a
really neat detail of how you see the
spirit talking but you hear the spirit
on the phone hope i'm explaining it
correctly because it's a detail i really
liked in the movie and if you're not
seeing it the way i'm trying to explain
it i apologize there is an arc in this
movie or at least with a character in
this movie where i get what they were
trying to do but the character shows up
at a point and then he's not really used
and then he's he's almost used and then
not used i get what they were trying to
illustrate with that element of a family
dynamic it's one of these situations
where if i found out the character was
added to the movie when the movie was
almost done filming i wouldn't be the
least bit surprised i mean it works for
the movie just not in the most organic
way but you know i guess it works but in
the end this is scott derrickson doing a
thriller in a way i've come to know him
to do a thriller you take something that
sounds cookie cutter but you add
elements and details in there to make it
stand out in terms of filming and
execution there are movies that
take place in the 70s but you can still
tell you're dealing with a 2020
zeitgeist you might be able to fool a
couple people that don't know about this
movie and be like oh yeah it was totally
filmed in 1979 and they might actually
believe you again devil's in the details
i like this movie for that i always like
being surprised especially in this genre
don't go in expecting cheap thrills
don't get all drunk with your friends be
like all right sweet yeah blood fest
it's not like that this is a missing
person's thriller with a supernatural
element to it because i'm probably gonna
buy this one on blu-ray in the end i
walked away go and i just what a good
week of movies elvis black phones a good
time and as i mentioned earlier this
video is brought to you by cook unity
cook unity is a chef to consumer
platform delivering freshly prepared
pre-selected meals right to your
doorstep and they're prepared in
regional micro kitchens not big
warehouses or production facilities
meals arrive fully cooked so all you
have to do is warm it up you're good to
go and i noticed they're kept cool on
the packaging but they're not frozen i
appreciate that they even have vegan
paleo and gluten-free options i'm a
creature a habit you know i tend to eat
the same thing every day just because it
works so it's cool that there's a
service like this that makes it easy for
me to branch out in my weekly flavor
profile the previous meal that i had was
chicken cordon bleu by chef reuben
garcia i'm 50 50 as well or not i'm
going to throw a house party order about
10 of these meals and pull the doubt
fire they probably won't know they
weren't prepared or made in my house
sorry chefs i might take the credit so
click the link below go to
cookunity.com use my code john's 50 to
get 50 off of your first order of cook
unity meals try it out for yourself
life's too short to not eat good food
where's the black phone have you seen it
what did you think about it or what's a
thriller movie that you thought was
going to be a cliche horror movie but it
ended up having so much more to it
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you